[Musica]
Kabul l'aeroporto a midcharzai ricordo
bene quelle ore perché quelle furono le
prime ore in assoluto in cui la capitale
afghana era finita completamente sotto
il controllo dei talebani l'ultimo
americano aveva lasciato il paese
l'ultimo americano è l'ultimo soldato
della coalizione internazionale dopo 20
anni aveva lasciato il paese nella notte
non sapevamo non si sapeva cosa sarebbe
successo Era Certo che il rischio dei
talebani dilagante nel paese avrebbe
prodotto esecuzioni guerra civile e
molto altro Questo era vero fino a un
certo punto le tv nazionali erano
scappate non c'era più nessuno penso vi
ricorderete tutti quella agosto con i
Cargo Eric 130 italiani che fuggivano
dall'aeroporto caricando tutti gli
afgani che avevano collaborato con le
operazioni internazionali e con
l'esercito italiano e non solo
Quella fu l'unica diretta al mondo
scoprì poi da quell'aeroporto nelle
prime ore sotto il totale controllo dei
talebani
io Scelsi di andare lì ed eravamo solo
10-14 giornalisti circa di tutto il
mondo indipendenti proprio nel momento
in cui riflettori Si spensero perché
secondo me è fondamentale esserci quando
non c'è nessuno quando tutto quello che
di brutto può accadere accade Sta a noi
riaccendere quei riflettori e
documentare e così abbiamo fatto
entrando illegalmente dallo Uzbekistan a
piedi e trovandoci poi finalmente Dopo
quasi due giorni di viaggio proprio in
quel giorno a Kabul
questa immagine
vi dà l'idea
che erano le persone che ci circondavano
in quel momento
quelle bandiere bianche sono le
repubbliche e la bandiera della Non è
più la bandiera della Repubblica afgana
Ma la bandiera delle delle mirato
islamico dell'Afghanistan Questo è
l'anno zero di quel paese
camminavo lungo una via stavo cercando
di riportare le manifestazioni delle
donne vi ricorderete erano poche ma
erano costanti le donne che vedevano
pian piano i loro diritti sempre più
negati ovviamente è stata una cosa a
fasi tuttora ci sono diritti ancora per
le donne ma sono sempre più cancellati
camminavo lungo questa via c'era un muro
molto lungo e dei vari sistemi di difesa
che erano pensati proprio inizialmente
per difendersi dai talebani che però ora
erano al potere nella capitale una
macchina mi taglia la strada di colpo
quattro uomini scendono giù sono vestiti
di nero quasi tutti cercano di
sequestrarmi Io avevo il cellulare la
telecamera cellulare come telecamera
sulla stickcam e mi sono girato di colpo
Ho cercato di divincolarmi sono corso
indietro ovviamente non tornavo
all'hotel mi avrebbero seguito vado in
un'altra direzione lungo questo muro e
una pattuglia talebana mi Intercetta
si ferma scendono degli uomini io mi
avvicino loro e ovviamente in quel
momento mi rendo conto che l'unica
soluzione la meno peggio tra degli
uomini sconosciuti che potevano
tranquillamente di essere di ISIS lì c'è
un ISIS che si chiama Easy scappa
l'isis dell'area e la pattuglia talebana
gli stessi talebani che ammazzavano i
miei colleghi reporter che li avevano
ucciso uno proprio il mese prima però
erano in quel momento il governo le
autorità il meno peggio mi sono buttato
verso i talebani i quali hanno più o
meno capito ma non troppo ho detto
cabarian impasto la lingua locale dei
talebani giornalista ho fatto vedere
l'atleto stampa firmato da zabiolà
mujahid Il portavoce dei talebani il
quinto uomo più ricercato della terra
che era diventato pubblico proprio nella
presa di Kabul non è servito niente Mi
hanno tirato un pugno in faccia
meno sbattuto dentro e avevo tre uomini
Armate tre talebani intorno a me che mi
stavano portando non si sa dove
a quel punto ho pensato vabbè è andata
ho dato tutto quello che poteva questa
terra è finita cerchiamo di finirla in
bellezza passatemi il termine e Mi sono
iniziato a guardare attorno per capire
come finirla in bellezza non è andata
così per fortuna La situazione è
cambiata mi sono reso conto che ci
stavano portando in un edificio questo
edificio scoprì poi era la sede dei
servizi segreti della Repubblica afghana
La Repubblica precedente a quei giorni
ora è diventato un centro di detenzione
mi portano i piani superiori e lì mi
trattengono dicono che resterò lì per
giorni non si capisce non tutti parlano
inglese ovviamente il mio Dari L'altra
lingua parlata in Afghanistan non è
sufficiente È quasi del tutto assente in
quel contesto mi tengono lì
inizio diplomaticamente a trovare un
modo circondato da tutti questi uomini
non era una cella ma era una stanza
appunto adibita cella cerco di
contrattare Per far sì che il mio
traduttore venga chiamato ce la faccio
dopo 8 ore viene chiamato il mio
traduttore entra e gli dicono Questo è
quello che lui mi ha tradotto possiamo
rilasciare il giornalista italiano
possiamo farlo ma a condizione che firmi
un foglio in cui dichiara sotto la sua
responsabilità che non filmerà nulla
contro il governo talebano che sarà
vantaggio solo nostro e non firmerà
niente
delle manifestazioni soprattutto quelle
delle donne
immaginate cosa ho risposto Ovviamente
ero circondato di uomini armati talebani
il mio traduttore mi traduce io li
guardo e con gentilezza ma fermezza
seppur preoccupato dico no scusate non è
possibile e mi risiedo
i talebani non abituati a un no
tantomeno che ha un occidentale si
iniziano a infervorare scuotono una
mazza si guardano intorno e iniziano a
parlare col mio traduttore e gli fanno
ben capire e questo lui poi me lo
traduce si gira e vi dico direttamente
la traduzione mi guarda e dice loro
hanno detto che se tu non firmi il
foglio Io passerò dei brutti guai non
potevo lasciar morire il mio traduttore
D'altro canto non potevo firmare quel
documento non esiste il mio compito è
raccontare la verità e portare al più
efficacemente possibile censurare quella
cosa significava censurare il paese e la
ragione per cui ero lì
mi viene un'idea
non posso farlo morire ovviamente ma
posso trarre qualcosa che servirà
all'informazione in quel momento gli
dico traducili io lo firmo questo foglio
però me lo fate fotografare mi
permettete di fotografare la situazione
già pensando che ampliando L'obiettivo
della camera avrei potuto fotografare i
loro volti tra le varie cose ed è quello
che realmente succede riesco a
fotografare il documento e non era
ancora uscito tutti ne parlavano i
prigionieri che venivano arrestati i
giornalisti che venivano arrestati
chiunque venisse arrestato in quel
momento gli facevano firmare questo
foglio ma non stupidi non lo
rilasciavano in modo che il governo
talebano potesse dichiarare al mondo che
nulla veniva censurato in Afghanistan
non c'è problema Non vi preoccupate non
è così riesco a fotografare col
documento e quello rimane in quel
momento in quelle settimane L'unica
prova storica che talebani imponevano la
censura sul paese facendo firmare i
prigionieri
è servito è servito a portare un pezzo
di informazioni di quello che accadeva
In più ho i volti i volti di chi ha
incarcerato i volti di chi immediata la
situazione i volti di chi ci teneva
dentro i volti di chi picchiava a me non
è successo per fortuna sono stato molto
fortunato quando mi arrestarono in
Bielorussia non andò così bene
[Applauso]
questo è la foto di cui vi parlavo
Questo è il documento e guardate il
talebano con la mazza
Ecco fa quasi sorridere detta così
Peccato che questo è l'ultimo è l'unico
documento storico che abbiamo di quelle
vicende ma avviciniamoci un attimo a noi
chilometricamente andiamo verso i
Balcani
Natale 2020
Per me il Natale è un momento molto
particolare io lo vivo con una certa
frenesia ansia per me il Natale è un
momento di intervento operativo serve a
rivolgersi e a capire quello che abbiamo
intorno e serve a cercare di dare di
impegnarsi per qualcosa migliorare la
condizione della vita delle persone non
ho la nostra stessa fortuna io lo vivo
così vivo anche gli altri giorni come
Penso abbiate intuito ma in particolare
per me il Natale iniziare a ragionare e
mi resi conto che in quel momento c'era
un'emergenza profughi c'è sempre
un'emergenza profughi ma era diversa
nella neve in Bosnia c'erano migliaia di
profughi che a causa di incendio erano
fatti stati fatti uscire da decentri di
permanenza e si trovavano al freddo e al
gelo c'erano già state amputazioni
Quando io raccolsi le informazioni
e pensai che fosse ora di fare qualcosa
in più accade il terremoto in Croazia a
due passi dalla zona della Bosnia Dove
si trovano i profughi iniziai a lanciare
dei messaggi WhatsApp Facebook raccolsi
circa 70 volontari e 12 camion di aiuti
umanitari coordinandoci con le necessità
dell'associazione locali in 24 ore più
tutti i soldi che ci servivano Questo è
il giorno prima di capodanno eram
passati alcuni giorni da Natale coordino
il giorno prima di Capodanno a capodanno
partiamo
questi sono alcuni dei profughi sotto la
neve che abbiamo contribuito ad aiutare
Tra l'altro la maggior parte di questi
profughi sono profughi afgani ho cercato
anche di mettere insieme quando ci siamo
resi conto della situazione ho
instaurato una serie di missioni dei
medici studenti medicina medici
infermieri che potessero fare i primi
trattamenti voi siete abituati che se
state male andate dal medico se sei un
profugo afgano bloccato nella neve in
Bosnia non penso che nessuno qua parli
il bosniaco immaginate un afgano
scappato dai talebani gli stessi
talebani di cui parlavo prima ma che non
erano ancora arrivati al potere ancora
si facevano esplodere è difficile che
abbiate cure mediche
ma ci sono due problemi due rischi da
risolvere il covid
2020/2021 far partire delle missioni di
intervento in Bosnia significava
rischiare di rimanere bloccati in
Slovenia in Croazia e poi in Bosnia per
settimane mesi in base alla geroidizione
di ogni paese significava rischiare con
i nostri soldi di rimanere bloccati lì
perché ovviamente Devi pagarti tu il
soggiorno in questi paesi significava
non farcela ad aiutare quelle persone
Il secondo problema è più importante il
divieto in Bosnia come anche in Serbia
non si può intervenire per aiutare i
profughi è vietato ti costa l'arresto o
l'espulsione quindi dobbiamo mettere a
disposizione la nostra libertà legale la
libertà di movimento il rischio era
concreto Sì però il nostro rischio era
perdere qualche giorno di carcere o mese
essere espulsi da un paese al massimo
rimanere bloccati in tre paesi per covid
il loro
era decisamente più alto
per tre mesi per tre mesi siamo riusciti
a tenere in vita 300 quasi 300 e 200 e
300 in questi bambini afgani e alcuni
iracheni
per tutti e tre mesi li abbiamo tenuti
in vita nella neve portandogli cibo
riscaldandoli dandoli della legna
dandogli tutto quello che potevamo
abbiamo contribuito a tenere in vita 300
persone in tre mesi
[Applauso]
è ancora molto toccante in realtà per me
rivedere queste immagini perché io non
ero ancora stato in Afghanistan qua e
vedere le persone che aveva aiutato
precedentemente poi il posto da cui
scappavano mi ha fatto rendere ancora
più consapevole non si smette mai
oggettivamente di essere consapevoli
bisogna sempre diventare più consapevoli
in ogni cosa e mi ha fatto molto
impressione a ricollegare come vedete
Questo è il classico copricapo
tradizionale di un'area dell'Afghanistan
Ma in queste due storie che vi ho
raccontato Abbiamo messo a disposizione
la nostra libertà di movimento legale e
rischio di arresto le nostre risorse nel
nostro tempo ma la volta in cui ho dato
di più è quando ho messo a disposizione
quando ho offerto la mia stessa vita
autunno 2014 camminavo in un campo
profughi gli azida in Turchia la Jazira
è un etnia e una religione penso vi
ricorderete del recente Premio Nobel per
la pace Nadia Murad una delle ragazze
che fu catturata stuprata torturata
seviziata e violentata da ISIS dai
califfato nero di ISIS e molte altre
ragazze per anni hanno subito questa
sorta in quel campo profughi in cui io
ero non c'erano quasi nessuna donna Non
c'era quasi nessuna donna c'erano solo
pochi uomini e qualche bambino e qualche
ragazzina La maggior parte erano state
rapite catturate dal califfato nero in
Siria e in Iraq
non so come spiegarlo se no
per me quando si ha la possibilità di
fare qualcosa e non la si fa si fa
qualcosa di sbagliato
ero in grado di poter intervenire ero
giovane preparato conoscevo l'area parlo
curdo seppur non fluentemente potevo in
qualche modo fare la mia parte la cosa
per me è insopportabile pesantemente
insopportabile era l'idea che in quel
momento nel 2014 così come oggi
esistesse una parte del mondo dove una
persona per il semplice sesso biologico
viene considerato un oggetto di scambio
violentatesiviziata
e io non facciossi niente
sono passati due anni da quella scelta
Dalla scelta di intervenire e nel 2017
sono sceso in Siria in rogiava nel nord
del paese a fianco dei curdi contro ISIS
contro il califfato nero perché due anni
perché se decidi quando morire morire
moriremo tutti in questa sala come fuori
ma se decidi quando morire Vuoi che la
tua vita così come la tua morte siano il
più utile possibile e per me l'utilità
era liberare Racca l'ex capitale dello
stato islamico in Siria impegnarmi nella
Liberazione e così abbiamo fatto
Queste sono alcune delle ragazze
yazidide Combattenti che sono state
liberate dal califfato e poi hanno
deciso di continuare
26 anni 23 e 21
Questa è una foto di Racca 2 km dal
centro del combattimento
sono rimasto vivo per miracolo non
credete ai soldati che vi dicono Sono
stato bravo sono rimasto vivo non
funziona così una guerra non si rimane
vivo perché si è bravo si può ridurre il
rischio si può intervenire si può fare
cose che possono essere utili ma non
funziona così
sono rimasto vivo per pura coincidenza e
per questo sento ulteriormente il dovere
di utilizzare le mie competenze
cresciute con la Siria con l'impegno in
Siria sono stato sette mesi e mezzo
per il prossimo e in questo caso
intervenendo con la comunicazione con il
giornalismo con il reportage di fronte
Questa foto l'ho scattata in Ucraina
Forse alcuni di voi mi hanno conosciuto
proprio per l'Ucraina in cui sono stato
tre mesi seguendo la battaglia di karkiv
la battaglia di Kiev il donniez che
lugansk come reporter di guerra con una
formazione Vedete un po' diversa da
altri colleghi Questa è la via per la
tristemente famosa buccia L'ho scattata
col mio drone
Questa è una foto che ha scattato il mio
cameraman mentre cercavo di analizzare
lo schianto di questo elicottero un
elicottero Russo abbattuto Stavo
analizzando l'aria intorno a me
per cercare di ricostruire non è
semplice non è sempre possibile sempre
facile farlo ma il mio impegno ora è
quello di cercare di sconfiggere tutte
le propagande e portare quello che
realmente accade ed è anche per questo
che vi dico che la maggior parte delle
ricostruzioni che sentite nei
telegiornali non sono reali è
difficilissimo ricostruire esattamente
quello che accade ma in alcuni casi come
questo si può fare
Cosa hanno in comune tutte queste storie
che vi ho raccontato soprattutto le
prime tre prima dell'Ucraina ve lo
spiego con un esempio Immagino che qui
Voi in sala ognuno di voi abbia un amico
un parente una persona amata che ha
subito o sta subendo in questo momento
un'ingiustizia Ditemi se sbaglio
Probabilmente voi stessi avete subito
un'ingiustizia immaginiamo uno scenario
immaginate che voi è il vostro amico
amica Siete
in un ufficio siete in un ufficio State
lavorando entrambi voi è il vostro
collega che anche il vostro amico il
vostro collega viene accusato
ingiustamente di qualcosa di aver rubato
qualcosa di valore dall'ufficio in cui
lavorate è una persona amata è un vostro
caro amico volete aiutarlo quindi e in
più sapete
che l'accusa infondata è un'accusa
ingiusta perché lo sapete perché viene
accusato in uno specifico tempo in cui
sapete che lui era con voi
siete un testimone chiave
stanno cercando di incastrarlo È palese
lo sapete me ne rendete perfettamente
conto vi fanno capire dall'alto della
vostra azienda che se voi parlerete
sarete voi a perdere il lavoro a perdere
l'unica sussistenza per la vostra
famiglia per i vostri figli per pagare
le bollette
tutto quello che vi serve dovete quindi
sacrificare qualcosa per fare la cosa
giusta e anche per amore dall'altro lato
se non lo farete sarà il vostro amico a
perdere il lavoro e a subire tutte
queste conseguenze Voi sapete pure
ingiustamente
e vi ricordo che se davanti a
un'oppressione a un'ingiustizia si
riesca a guardare si è complici provate
davanti una violenza a girarvi
dall'altro lato a non fare niente a chi
pensate di andare a vantaggio della
aggredito dell'aggressore
dell'aggressore
amore
l'amico in questo caso giustizia Sapete
bene in sede consapevoli siete voi
testimoni sapete che sta subendo
un'ingiustizia amore e Giustizia senza
senza
il coraggio di agire non servono a
niente
chiedetevi un po' In quale Benedetto
mondo volete vivere in questo tipo di
mondo qua quello in cui vi accusano
ingiustamente per qualcosa e le persone
amate non faranno niente
Per aiutarvi per paura Io non ci sto Mi
spiace Io scelgo agire scelgo il
coraggio È proprio per questo che
sacrificherò qualcosa E perderò qualcosa
in tanti paesi io non posso entrare in
Tanti luoghi avrò dei problemi e li avrò
ancora ne avrò di più Fino a quando
Resterò in vita fino a quando esalonerò
l'ultimo respiro ma scelgo questa via
non ne scelgo altre
e Voi direte Vabbè ma tu sei stato in
guerra sei stato in situazioni estreme
sei stato in Siria c'è parlato
dell'Ucraina una Gorno carabaken in
Afghanistan sei preparato cioè è normale
che tu sei preparato al coraggio No in
realtà se avete ascoltato bene l'esempio
di prima dell'ufficio il coraggio non
risiede in qualcuno di noi ma in ognuno
di noi in ognuno di voi
si tratta di realizzare la
consapevolezza e la coerenza
di agire se veramente siete delle
persone che amate o che vi ritenute vi
ritenete delle persone giuste dovete
avere il coraggio di agire camminiamo
camminiamo camminiamo troppo spesso
su questa terra in questa vita
chiedendoci quanto possiamo avere quanto
possiamo tenere quanto possiamo
guadagnare è troppo poco Troppo poco
spesso ci godiamo quanto ci chiediamo
quanto possiamo dare quanto possiamo
fare la differenza quanto possiamo
migliorare il mondo in cui viviamo in
cui viviamo Tra l'altro tutti
c'è un ragazzo un amico un giovane
italiano nonché un giovane Fiorentino
morto in battaglia contro ISIS nelle
stesse unità in cui ero io
ha perso la vita nel 2019 Lorenzo
orsetti detto orso che scriveva nel suo
testamento ogni tempesta comincia con
una singola goccia cercate di essere voi
quella goccia Quindi domattina questo ve
lo chiedo io quindi domattina quando vi
alzerete accenderete la luce chiedetevi
che cosa potete fare che cosa potete
fare al mondo in cui vivete magari
chiamate un amico che non sentite da
tanto tempo che magari in difficoltà o
in depressione fermate un'ingiustizia
interrompete interrompete un'accusa
insensata come nell'esempio dell'ufficio
agite date qualcosa
perché se ognuno di noi darà qualcosa
le persone come Lorenzo non saranno
costrette a dare tutto Io scelgo il
coraggio voi Scegliete il coraggio
[Applauso]